حييت سفحك عن بعد فحييني يا دجله الخير يا
ام البساتين يا نبعا افارقه على الكراهه
بين الحين والحين اني وردت عيون الماء
صافيه نبعا فنبعا فما كانت لتروينه ان
العراق يواجه تهديدا وجوديا بسبب شح
المياه
العراق البلد الذي تغنى ذات يوم بمياهه
وانهاره الشعراء ويقال ان اسمه مشتق من
عروق الشجر وفي روايه اخرى لانه يقع على
شاطئ اي دجله والفرات فيه مدينه البصره
التي عرفت في القرن العشرين بفينيسيا
الشرق لكثره القنوات المائيه التي كانت
تسير فيها القوارب عبر الاحياء السكنيه
لكن ماذا لو القينا اليوم نظره الى العراق
من الاعلى ماذا عن دجله الذي امتدح مياهه
الشاعر محمد مهدي الجواهري دون غيره من
مياه العالم ماذا عن الفرات الذي طار
المتنبي ومعروف الرصاف ذات يوم شوقا اليه
يعاني العراق موجه جفاف تعد الاسوا منذ
اربعين عاما بحسب البنك الدولي ليس لدى
العراق اليوم ما يكفي من المياه لتلبيه
احتياجاته ويتوقع في عام 2005 ان تكون
ملامح الجفاف الشديده اكثر وضوحا في عموم
البلاد وذلك مع جفاف شبه كلي لنهر الفرات
باتجاه الجنوب وتحول نهر دجله الى مجرى
مائي محدود الموارد ليس هذا هو السيناريو
الاسوا على الاطلاق فالسناريو الاسوا
يتوقع حدوثه مؤشر الاجهاد المائي بحلول
عام 2040 العراق بلد الانهار مهدد بان
يكون دون انهار
[موسيقى]
يعود تراجع منسوب المياه في العراق الى
اسباب مختلفه اهمها ارتفاع درجات الحراره
وندره الامطار التي تمثل نحو 30% من موارد
العراق المائيه في حين تمثل مياه الانهار
القادمه من تركيا وايران نحو 70 في المائه
ومن هنا فان المشكله الرئيسيه بحسب
التصريحات العراقيه ناتجه عن نسبه المياه
التي تغذي نهري دجله والفرات اللذين
يمثلان المصدر الرئيسي للمياه اذ ان سته
وخمسين في الماء من واردات نهر دجله
المائيه تاتي من تركيا وتاتي 12 في الماء
من وارداته من ايران ويحصل النهر على 22%
من مياهه من داخل العراق اما نهر الفرات
فيحصل على
88% من مياهه من تركيا وتسعه في الماء من
سوريا وثلاثه في الماء من الاراضي
العراقيه وي ما سبق ان تركيا تتحكم في
النسبه الكبرى من مياه النهرين في حين
تتحكم ايران في نسبه لا باس بها من مياه
دجله بنى التركيه 22 سدا ومحطه للطاقه
الكهرومائيه ومشروعات رين على نهري دجله
والفرات منذ عام
1974 وبنت ايران اكثر من عشره سدود على
روافد دجله منذ عام 2000 وهو ما ادى الى
تخريب مزارع في محافظات مثل ديالى التي
كانت معروفه بزراعه الخوخ والمشمش
والبرتقال والتمر ونتيجه لذلك انخفضت
المياه المتدفقه الى العراق بنسبه 50%
تقريبا على نهر الفرات وبنحو الثلث على
نهر دجله منذ بدء بناء السدود الرئيسيه في
سبعينيات القرن العشرين من الاسباب ايضا
قله سدود التخزين التي انشات على النهرين
فالسد الوحيد على نهر الفرات هو سد حديث ه
في حين ان سدود الرماد والفلوجه والهنديه
هي سدود تنظيميه لمرور المياه دون ان
تخزنها
[موسيقى]
لم يفلح العراق منذ منتصف القرن الماضي في
وضع حلول نهائيه لازمه المياه المتكرره
والتي تحولت الى ورقه ضغط بيد دولتي
المنبع تركيا وايران فاخفقت الحكومات
العراقيه في توقيع اتفاق ملزم مع الجارتين
يضمن حقوق بلاد ما بين النهرين اذ لا توجد
اتفاقيه محدده بين العراق وتركيا للتقاسم
في المياه باستثناء تفاهمات وبروتوكولات
مشتركه في بعض الحالات وتحتج تركيا في
رفضها التوصل الى اي اتفاقيه مع العراق
حول المياه بان العراق لم يقدم اي دليل
يثبت قدرته على اداره الموارد المائيه
وترى انه لا فائده من اطلاق مياه ستنتهي
في الخليج دون الاستفاده منها اما مع
ايران فتوجد بنود اتفاقيه الجزائر الموقعه
عام
1975 التي ورد فيها بروتوكول يحدد كيفيه
التصرف في
نهرا وواديا الى ان الاتفاقيه معطله منذ
عام
1980 مع بدء الزيارات الرسميه بين بغداد
وانقر مؤخرا يحاول العراق اليوم وضع
اتفاقيه واضحه خاصه بعد اتمام سد ايليس
التركي الذي سيغير المعادله لنهر دجله
فهذا السد سيحول النهر الى قناه متدفقه في
داخل الحدود التركيه بدلا من قناه تتدفق
الى خارج الحدود في رايك هل تنجح المساعي
العراقيه الاخيره في حل ازمه المياه
[موسيقى]